everybody what's going on welcome to a
video that's really going to serve two
purposes on my channel the first purpose
is a sort of crash course in the
object-oriented programming the second
one is actually just to be the second
part of my tkinter kind of intermediate
series so depending on which one you're
here for obviously your your goals here
are going to vary but we are going to
make a tkinter application but you don't
really need to know anything about
tkinter and there's really no
prerequisite here other than that you
need to at least sort of understand
Python happy help otherwise let's go
ahead and get started so we're going to
go ahead and just import tkinter as TK
because we're going to be using tkinter
if you're not familiar with what tkinter
is it's a module to make gooeys or
graphical user interfaces um and also if
you're interested I'll put the link to
the to the tkinter the tkinter playlist
will be in the description anyways so um
so first of all what is object-oriented
programming so it's kind of like this
elusive thing that I think a lot of
people don't even understand I know I
didn't even understand I knew you know
about object-oriented programming and I
knew Python was an object-oriented
programming language but I don't really
know what object-oriented and
object-oriented programming you're going
to describe object-oriented programming
as programming using objects basically
that's how you're going to describe it
because that's what it is but to
somebody who doesn't understand like
what the hell is even an object that's
really confusing so the idea of
object-oriented programming is to create
these object instances using codes an
object only a programming is really just
like a paradigm that you would use or a
structure that's basically all you're
doing is you're structuring the code of
your program to act and just basically
be structured in a certain way so does
simply programming object-oriented
programming actually isn't doing
anything it's just the the structure of
your code so what happens is you make
these
classes and all this and then you assign
a variable to these classes and then
within the classes you have what looks
to be functions but really they're
called methods but they do the same
thing as functions and then you can say
you know variable dot method of whatever
the fun or variable out function so to
speak and you can do things within you
can pass variables like you could pass
parameters to functions and all this and
its really fancy but it's really
confusing at the same time but at the
end of the day what it does is when you
call upon a class it's going to return
an object and we assign that object to a
variable and then we can later call that
variable do a dot and then the method
and call upon those individual methods
or what appear to us to be functions and
to do more stuff so that's the idea
let's go ahead and actually see it in an
example so first we're going to we're
going to call our color define our class
rather and we're just going to call this
class and it's going to be C of BTC app
so see if VDC is just a business right C
of B DC and then we're making an
application for it if you're not
following the tkinter application that's
all you need to know when you define a
class you do not need parentheses you
don't have to pass anything through or
anything like that you could just do
colon and then boom you're ready to find
your methods but we're actually we do
have something we want to add here but
these are not parameters so to speak
what you can put in here is inheritance
so if you want this class to inherit
inherit attributes of another class that
you've already made that's what you put
in here so for example we want to
inherit from TK dot capital T lowercase
K I guess I should also add I'm
programming this in Python 3 so if
you're in Python 2 the major difference
here is importing interests EK you would
capitalize this T in tkinter that's for
Python 2 but if you're in Python 3
that's a lower case but just keep that
in mind so that's that we want to
inherit from C of BTC all right mean I'm
sorry we want to inherit from tktk so
it's just this TK class within tkinter
so now what well it's not always the
case but in most cases you're
see the following you're gonna see
somebody do like define underscore
underscore init underscore underscore
and then it's going to have some
parameters usually what is this okay
well the init functionality here and
it's really a method even though it
looks like a function and acts like a
function it's a method the init method
is going it's like initialize right it's
going to initialize with your class so
when you call upon the class this will
always run and so the idea is you know
think of it like if you're you know
restarting your computer there are some
things that you want immediately to
happen right you want your desktop show
up so explorer.exe is going to start
running and you want your mouse to just
work right away you want your keyboard
to load you want all these like the code
that corresponds to the major things to
load but you might not necessarily want
to load up Skype and be tracked by the
NSA or you might not want to you know
start playing music so you want to make
some choices later on so in your you
know computer class you would have you
know play music as method but it
wouldn't be play music under your
initialization method right but there
are some things like I say like loading
up a desktop loading your mouse to work
your keyboard your screen you know to
output data to your screen that kind of
stuff you don't want that to be an
initialization and you want you want
that every time so it just makes sense
to be an Indian it function so then
you're going to see people pass through
self self is implied no matter what you
actually don't have to pass self at all
in a few scenarios it depends how you
structure it of course but you can't
structure it in a way that you don't
even ever have to pass self but Guido
says to do it so you got to do it but
it's just the first parameter basically
of every method in the first variable
rather but then after self you might not
see anything but you might see args and
kwargs so then you know like what are
these args and kwargs so you'll see
something like this you might just see
this actually that's bad convention and
just to say again self doesn't have to
be there but you can also call self
anything you wanted you could call self
you could call self boobs if you really
wanted you can get away with that but
it's just convention that we call itself
because people understand what that is
immediately when they read it they see
self and they're like okay he's you know
following convention that's what that
parameter is because otherwise you could
actually you could say in theory you're
ignoring self and you could just put you
eat or something like that
and that actually is a parameter itself
is just implied and so it's just really
confusing so we put self there now you
see these asterisks and these asterisks
correspond to args and Coors what most
people are going to do unless they're
jerks
they're gonna write args and they're
gonna write kwargs again you don't have
to put that there that's just convention
that that people put it there but it is
nice that you put args and kwargs there
what's the difference between args and
kwargs now args short for arguments is
in any number of variables it's really
unlimited it just it just basically says
like hey this is really open-ended you
could pass as much crap through here as
you want
that's what args is so you can pass in
theory let's let's visualize this as
variables that are being passed through
finally you've got kwargs kwargs our
keyword arguments and the best way to
envision this is that you're passing
through dictionaries that's almost
always the case it's just just vision it
like you know it's you pass through
variables here you pass through
dictionaries and chords boom done easy
enough so this is again just a crash
course and so I just think that if you
just visualize it that way you're good
like 99.9 percent of the time so once
you have that um we'll go ahead and add
a colon here and we'll add what we want
to initialize so within our knit
function what we're going to go ahead
and do is go ahead and run TK capital t
underscore k under speriod underscore
underscore init underscore underscore
and then in here we're going to run the
same thing as before itself and then
args if we have them and then kwargs
so we're just running basically within
our initialization function we're also
being like yeah let's initialize tkinter
- done easy peasy lemon squeezy so so
now what we're going to be doing here is
this is a tkinter application so we have
what we're going to call it a container
and that's going to contain everything
in our tkinter app so that's always
going to be here we're always going to
have a container that we're going to
populate so within our initialization
function we're going to go ahead and
define this this container so let's go
ahead and add our container here so we
would say container equals TK frame and
then self frame is it's a part of
tkinter and frame is basically what you
would think of as a window it's just you
know the edge of the window it's a frame
easy enough so now with tkinter now this
is kind of going away from object on
your programming to an extent here
although to use tkinter you use
object-oriented programming but with you
kinter you have two options for like
shoving stuff into your window the first
option is to just pack it in so you can
use pack and like it sounds just like it
is or it basically acts just like it
sounds and you can kind of dictate where
stuff goes but for the most part it's
like you got a big bag and you're just
shoving crap in there and like that's
what pack does so you can kind of say I
want this to be on the left side or I
want this to be over here or whatever
but for the most part pack just like
shoves it in there and that's it
so I personally don't like to use pack
all the time but if you're making a
really quick window maybe you've got
like two or three elements that are
going in that window packs actually
easier so I use pack sometimes but if
you're making a really complex window
and you want to be able to organize
stuff just so you're gonna use grid but
for now we're gonna use pack and you're
gonna see in a second we're going to use
grid anyways but so for example what we
can do is we'll do container dot hack
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to use a few parameters here we're
going to say to the side what side you
want to pack this stuff to easy enough
we're going to say top so it's at the
top
and then you have a fill and we're going
to say fill is both and then you're
going to have expand and we're going to
say that equals true so let me let's see
when we use fill what Phil does is it
fill will fill in the space that you
have allotted the pack right so if you
pack something into a space what Phil's
going to do is say okay let's fill this
entire space right
but then expand what expand does is say
if there's any more white space at all
in the window
irrespective of a irrespective of where
we said we're going to pack this stuff
you can expand if there is space so
expand is like beyond the limits that
you set and then fill is just like let's
fill in the limits that you set okay so
here now let's go ahead and do some
basic configuration so we're going to do
a container dot grid underscore row
configure and this is a grid underscore
row configure as a part of tkinter TK
okay so this part of our little
inheritance that we're doing here so
grid and then row configure this is some
simple configuration and then what we're
going to say is 0 and then weight equals
1 I'll explain those in just a second
and but we're going to do the exact same
thing that was row configure now we're
going to change Row 2 now B column
configure easy now
um the 0 is basically setting of the
minimum size here so we just say 0 is
the minimum and then weight equals 1 and
this is really like a priority kind of
thing like who gets priority we're just
going to say there's you know just 1 for
both of these easy enough now we're
going to go ahead and specify a
dictionary this is going to be a massive
part of our key control application but
not really so massive - object-oriented
programming but we're just gonna say
self dot frames and self doubt frames
equals a
empty dictionary but you can probably
start to guess where this dictionary is
going to go anyway uh then we're going
to say frame oops not all caps their
frame equals a start page start page
does not exist yet we're going to we're
going to define start page in a little
bit but start page is going to be like
that initial page that we run on so
frame equals start page and a start page
and then we're going to pass through a
container whatever that container is and
then self easy-peasy
next we want um the weight our reference
the page in self dot frames right now we
just have one that we're going to stuff
in there for now just to show the
functionality but eventually we're going
to have a lot of frames and the way that
this is going to work for our tkinter
application is we make a bunch of frames
let me slap them all in that container
but the frame that's on top is the one
we're interacting with and then whenever
we want to change that we basically
enter some code and or click a button
that's going to run some code and it's
going to bring a different one to the
front and that's how we have multiple
like not necessarily multiple windows
that's how we have like one application
that can load different types of windows
so many way frame start page contain
yourself and then what we do is we're
going to say self dot frames and we're
going to say start page and then we're
just going to say equals equals the
frame okay so um so then now we're going
to use the grid and we're going to say
frame dot grid and this is why grid is
superior and it's go we say we want this
grid to be on row 0 and then column 0
and then we do sticky and that is we're
gonna say NS e.w now I'm going to
explain this first of all grid again
grid is the kind of opposite to Patton
opposite but it's your other choice
right you can either pack or you can do
grid and grid is basically it's just
like it's sound
so you assign you assign some frame to
the grid and the grid you say okay what
row what column do you want it to be in
and unlike setting for familiar with
matplotlib you can also use a grid
functionality but you have to predefine
the whole grid and then you can say okay
I want this and this part of the
greatness but if you specified something
outside of the grid you wouldn't get
away with it right you would do an error
so but with tkinter when you make a grid
basically it's going to just kind of
conform to whatever you say
so you could say grid bro equals 0 comma
equals 0 and then we could also we could
throw it you don't have to copy this but
you could say row equals 110 column
equals 110 and you would get away with
that just fine now it's not gonna make
the window huge it's going to assume
there's all these other rows and columns
that we might populate later but right
now it's going to put these two things
like basically right next to each other
because the other rows and columns are
just empty whereas if you're familiar
with matplotlib it makes all of the rows
and columns so every like cell so to
speak the exact same size tkinter
doesn't do that it just kind of helps
you with like setting things up so every
cell is as big as you need it to be
finally we have this sticky um parameter
and what this is is I'm pretty sure it's
just north south east west
um and what sticky does is it says like
I want to it's even think of it like
alignment only alignment Plus stretch so
sticky I guess and so if you say I want
something to be sticky to the north
right it's going to align everything up
top and if you do South everything a
bomb east everything to the right west
everything to the left but if you said
like sticky east west right or II W it's
going to stretch everything in the
center but if you said north-south it
would stretch everything from the top to
the bottom but not to the edges but if
you say north-south east-west it's going
to stretch everything to the size of
that window so once you've done that the
next thing that you would do is like you
can do a self self dot show on your
school
or frame and then what frame do you
actually want to show and we're going to
say start page so then we have self that
show frame start page and show frame
doesn't quite exist yet but we're going
to basically use a built in
functionality with tkinter here so we're
done with our initialization and of
course we always you know we're
initializing so that's why we're always
going to pull up start frame or I mean
start page rather first
so now we'll come down here and we're
going to define show underscore frame
and then we're going to obviously pass
through self and then conte
controller so um for show frame this is
a really simple method here it's just
going to say frame equals self dot
frames uh controller here and then
finally a frame dot TK raised and what
TK raise is going to do is that's going
to raise it to the front okay
so there's really no ordering here it's
just you know whatever is behind the
front page is just being hidden but then
we finally will raise one up to the
front and so frame here self dot frames
is corresponding here which is all the
frames and we've got this container
control or whatever that's being you
know this is the key right and then so
we're looking for the value of self dot
frames with this key and then whatever
that is is being you know thrown into
frame and then we're saying frame dot
t-- k raised we're going to run this
method on that and the reason why we can
do that is because we've inherited TK TK
so that's great it seems like though we
don't have a start page so we need a
start page and so to make our start page
luckily there's not too much code here
so what we've done so far is basically
the baseline code that's necessary for
adding pages so it might this tutorial
is kind of long so it might seem like
you know making windows oh my gosh this
is really daunting but really this is
the baseline and then adding pages to
that baseline is like really simple so
let's go ahead and add an example page
so we're going to say
class start page and the page that we're
going to start is TK arrow the we're
going to hear it sorry right in here it
from TK dot frame so all this stuff from
the frame basically we're going to
inherit that way don't have to call a
call upon all that and then this
function or I mean this class rather is
going to have as well an initialization
method but like a function so again this
runs immediately when we call this this
class so we're going to say define
underscore underscore underscore
underscore and then again we have self
and then the parent and then the
controller and we're going to initialize
a TKO frame okay so it's basically the
same sense or concept that we did right
up here so we're going to do
TK dot frame and then we're going to do
dot underscore underscore init
underscore underscore and then the same
thing here self parent in the parent
what's the parent class basically parent
class will be Co PDC app right that's
our main our main class here so now we
have TK frame and then we're gonna we're
just going to pass through some tkinter
code just so we see this start page so
basically we'll just we'll use a label
and we'll say label equals t k dot label
and that we're going to do self of
course and then we're just going to put
in some text so TK dot label obviously
this is something built into tkinter
this is how we add text to a tkinter
window so self text and we'll just call
this start page and then you can add
another thing which is font and it's a
good idea to go ahead you mean you could
use the default fonts if you wanted but
it's a good idea to go ahead and define
some fonts so we're going to say font
equals and this will be large underscore
font um so now let's go to the very top
and define a variable of or really a
kind of constant of large font so our
large font will be large underscore
fonts and then here is where you just
specify the font type and the font size
will say the font type verdana
and then size 12 now I know like 12
sounds not like a large font but for
like Windows that's actually kind of a
large font as you'll see but you can
change this later on if you want and we
might make that a little bigger but for
the most part that's like a large font
and you have smaller fonts like ten or
eight or something so we'll come down
now to the very bottom a font large font
that's totally fine now what we have to
do is we want to add this to our window
so we've just defined it right and
really what we've done since this is
object-oriented programming this is your
class what we've done is we've taken
this class and we've created the object
right this class returns an object and
we've returned that object to label but
it's all we've done so it's just an
object now we actually have to do
something with that object so what we're
going to do is we're going to say label
diet pack and then we say so we're using
pack because really this is just one
thing right so if you just have like one
two three four things that you're adding
to this window or really just one or two
things it's really easy just to pack it
in there otherwise I would you always
use grid but since this is such a basic
example we'll just use pack and then so
label dot pack and so again this TK
label is running the initialization
right when we call TK dot label it's
running basically label the label method
it's returning all of this stuff but
then we can also do label dot pack which
is a method right and then we're going
to go label dot pack and then we're
going to say pad why 10 and then pad x
equals 10 because this is just going to
put it everywhere basically and so we
want to have some padding on the top and
bottom so it looks you know neat so
we've got that and now we're ready to
actually call this into reality anyway
app equals C of BTC app empty parms
and then app dot main loop this is
tkinter code ok so just because you're
making a class doesn't mean you have to
do this but of course see a BDC app
that's up here which is inheriting TK TK
assigning to app and then we're doing F
dot main loop which since it inherited
from TK TK we're getting away with
saying dot main loop which is tkinter
functionality and we're ready to run so
hopefully this has been a really long
tutorial so I probably have some sort of
typo somewhere but let's see so say yes
to run it pops up nope no problems
actually whoops hello so here's our
starting window having really hard time
moving it around there we go so this is
our window we've got a start page here
and all of that so now you're done so
see how easy that was so if you made it
this far without closing the window in
like confusion frustration or just
straight-up boredom congratulations
Oh chances are you probably have some of
those things though and I do just want
to say that it does get better as far as
you know all this code that's required
to make your starting window so aside
from you know this this is an actual
page that we've added this code here and
understanding it is basically the base
line it's the foundation to the rest of
your tkinter application so once you
have this you never really have to code
this kind of code again so this is just
your baseline then every time you add a
page you just basically have to do this
so this is any any tkinter window you've
made in the past you just kind of
convert it right here and you add your
tkinter code right here and that's a new
page basically then once we have
multiple pages will actually start
stuffing all the pages in the self dot
frames here and then we'll have like a
little for loop here and that's what
we'll use to bring frames up but it's
actually a lot easier later on now of
course you know making custom tkinter
windows is hard no matter which window
you're making but you don't have to
worry about like this code so the
baseline is done and now we can just
refer you to add any kind of pages
we want and then eventually we add like
buttons that help us navigate to all
those pages and that's kind of a
challenge passing parameters through
functions through buttons but we'll get
there easy enough so anyways if you guys
have any questions or comments feel free
to post them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching things for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time